السلام عليكم ايه الاخبار سقعانين زي
حالات صح
لا لا انا اوكي
انا مؤمن جدا ان كل واحد فينا في حاجه
بتميزه يعني انت في حاجه انت كويس فيها
اكتر من الناس اللي حواليك مش شرط تكون
احسن واحد في الدنيا بس في حاجه انت مميز
فيها قوي
ممكن تكون سمكه قوي سريع في الجري عندك
جود جينز ممكن تكون سمه عقليه يعني كويس
جدا في الرياضيات تحل مسائل الفيزياء
بسرعه
وفي حاجه كنت دايما يعني بحسد الناس اللي
موجوده عندهم وهي سرعه البديهه في الردود
عارف انت لما بتكون في خناقه مش في خناقه
في نقاش مع حد وبتلاقي
ان في ناس كده يعني ربنا حببهم موهبه ان
هو
ذهنه حاضر جدا بيقول رد
ما تعرفش ترد انت ممكن يكون معك الحق ما
تعرفش تاخده بعد ما النقاش ده بيخلص خلاص
وتهدى شويه ايه اللي بيحصل
بتجيلك الردود اللي هي بتطير الجباه اللي
هو لو كنت قلت كذا كان زماني مش عارف ايه
بس خلاص الموضوع انتهى
الحقيقه انا زوجتي عندها الموهبه دي عندها
سرعه البديهه في الردود
فما بعرفش اكسب نقاش خالص خالص
اه بالزبط
المشكله فين
المشكله
ان اي حد كويس في حاجه معينه هو مش عارف
ده لانها بالنسبه له سهله وبديهيه هو مش
عارف ان هو مميز فيها مش عارف ان هو كويس
قوي فيها انت بتبقى محتاج حد تاني هو اللي
يقول لك ان انت كويس في الحاجه دي
يعني على سبيل المثال
احسن حلاق في الدنيا
بيحتاج حد يحلق له
لان في حتت هو مش شايفها في حتت لازم حد
هو اللي يوريها له
الموضوع ده يعني عمال يتكرر قدام كتير جدا
وقادر افتكر لما ما كنتش اعرف ان انا نظري
ضعيف
اي حد يعني لبس نظاره متاخر شويه فقبل ما
يلبس نظاره هو ما كانش عارف ان هو نظره
ضعيف هو كان مفكر ان الناس كلها بتشوف
الدنيا كده يعني الحمد لله مش شايف حد
كتير لابس نظاره بس اللي عنده استجماتيزم
بيشوف الدنيا كده لو ماشي بالليل بتلاقي
ايه اشعه جايه من كل مكان شخص العادي
بيشوف الدنيا كده
عادي
فقبل ما اعرف ان انا نظري ضعيف كنت ماشي
انا وصديق وبعدين شوت لي على حاجه كده
بالليل قال لي عند البتاع اللي هناك دي
انا مش شايف حاجه خالص اقول له مش شايف
حاجه قال لي هناك اهي مش شايف حاجه لحد ما
رحت وكشفت وعملت نظاره
ويا للهول انتم يا جماعه بتشوف الدنيا
بالحلاوه دي
يعني فعلا في احسن من اللي انا كنت شايفه
اه فيه بس انا ما كنتش عارف
اي حد
عنده موهبه او عنده قدره او هو كويس في
حاجه زياده عن الناس اللي حواليه
الحاجه دي بتكون عامله زي الجوهره الجميله
ديت ولكن هي في كهف مظلم تحت الارض النور
ما بيوصلوش ولكن لو شعيت شويه نور على
الجوهره دي هتشوعي جمال وحلاوه وحاجه
جميله جدا
مين المفروض اللي يمسك المصباح ده وينور
لنا الحاجات الكويسه اللي فينا مين
اول حاجه بتيجي في بالي هي المدرسه
المفروض المدرسه هي بتساعد الطلاب ان هم
يكتشفوا الحاجات اللي هم كويسين فيها
ويناموا الحاجات ديت
يعني فكره ان الواحد يكون شاطر في كل حاجه
فكره خرافيه بصراحه ومش عارف ليه دايما
كان المدرسين في المدرسه عندنا يقول لك
الشاطر الشاطر في كل حاجه
لا عادي يعني ممكن اكون شاطر في حاجه وفي
حاجه تانيه بالنسبه لي صعبه جدا او مش
منطقيه بالنسبه لي
المدرسه
في الغالب
بتعامل الناس يعني سواسيه كاسنان المشط
عايزاهم كده دايما سواسيه وده مش صح يعني
ممكن واحد يكون سابق فعلا في واحد سابق لا
انزل مشي مع الجماعه طب في واحد ممكن يكون
متاخر شويه لان انت بليد
فدي بتبقى مشكله كبيره قوي المدرسه
الحقيقه يعني الدور الاساسي لها هو
الموضوع ده ولكن ما اظنش ان هو بيبقى في
الاولويات دلوقتي شيء جميل ان احنا بنعمل
ده في مدرسه فيعني اوكي الحاجه التانيه هي
الاهالي الاب والام الاب والام بيقع عليهم
مسئوليه كبيره بصراحه ان هم يعني يكتشفوا
ابنهم او بنتهم كويسين في ايه ويحاولوا
يناموا ده
للاسف
احنا عنينا متعوده انها تشوف القصور
بنشوف الحاجه اللي هو يعني مقصر فيها
ونقعد نقول له لا حس من دي اتطور شويه
نجيب له مدرسين فيها في حين ان مش منطقي
مش منطقي ان هو يكون كويس في كل حاجه
الاولى والافضل واللي اكثر من حيث العمليه
ان انت تنمي عنده الحاجات اللي هو كويس
فيها يسبق باقل مجهود هيبان فيه نتيجه
كويسه جدا في الموضوع ده
ايه الجديد اللي هتقوله يعني فبالتالي هو
مش بيكون افضل حد ان هو يقول لك ايه
الحاجه اللي انت كويس فيها اللهم الا
نادرا شويه يعني
طيب
الحاجات اللي انا اكتشفت ان انا كويس فيها
ما بتبانش من الاول يعني الموضوع بياخد
وقت وبعدين بتبص لورا وتشوف اه ده الموضوع
كان معي من زمان بس انا ما كنتش واخد بالي
زي ستيف جوبز كان بيقول كان اونلي
اللي هو انت بتقدر تشوف الحبكه او القصه
ماشيه ازاي لما تبص لورا لكن طول ما انت
عايشها انت ما انت شايف حاجه
الموضوع بدا من الثانويه العامه ان انا
كنت بحب
كنت بحب ابسط المفاهيم المعقده لاصحابي
يعني كنت احب اشارك معهم ازاي انا بذاكر
بذاكر امتى التقنيات اللي انا بستخدمها
بشرب ايه وانا بذاكر كل الحاجات دي
وكنت بستغرب جدا ان في جزء كبير جدا
معظمهم كان بيداري مش عايز يعرف حد حاجه
ما كانش يعني تسال حد بتذاكر كم ساعه
والله ما بذاكرش يا عم ده انا قاعد طول
النهار قدام التلفزيون طب بتذاكر ازاي او
ذاكرت الدرس ده لا والله ما ذاكرتش ده انا
يا عم مش عارف ايه
فدائما كان بيبقى فكره ان انا علشان ابقى
متميز لازم اللي حواليا كلهم يبقوا سيئين
كانت للاسف الشديد يعني لما رحت الكليه
الموضوع كان اصعب لان اي حد مر بالكليه
فانت بتذاكر الماده مرتين في السنه مره في
الميت ترم ومره في الفاينل كويس فانت في
الميت ترم محتاج تضغط المحتوى ده وتلاقيه
له طريقه للحفظ او حاجه تفتكروا بها زي
اغنيه او لحن او مقطوعه او بيت شعر او
كلمات تمشي مع بعضها اللي هي لو تعرفوا
الحاجات اللي زي دي كان على ايامنا في
الرياضيات
كل جبار ظالم جاتوه داهيه يعني هي بتاعه
برضو اليومين
دول المهم
وانا في الكليه اتعلمت فوتوشوب
ولقيت للاسف الشديد ما كانش في محتوى عربي
على اليوتيوب اه وقتها ما كانش فيه محتوى
عربي تعليمي للفوتوشوب على اليوتيوب تخيل
والكلام ده مش من بعيد الكلام ده من سبع
سنين بس
حصل طفره في يوتيوب بصراحه
فانا مش افضل حد بيعرف يستخدم فوتوشوب ومش
جرافيك ديزاينر ولكن انا اعرف قدر قدر
افضل من المبتدئ فاقدر اوصل له القدر ده
وبالفعل عملت الفيديو ده وصل تقريبا لاكتر
من 6 مليون واحد في اكتر من سته مليون
واحد ممكن يكونوا تعلموا اساسيات
الفوتوشوب من الفيديو ده
الموضوع مني اخد شويه وقت علشان ابدا
اراجع الحاجات اللي انا شايفها سهله
بالنسبه لي واشاركها مع اللي حواليا او
بسطها او اسهلها بالامثله كان شيء صادم
ان في شاب كان شغال معنا لما اكون شغال في
الهندسه كان خريج اداب قسم انجليزي اداب
قسم انجليزي وكان عنده مشكله في اللغه
الانجليزيه
كانت القواعد بالنسبه له مش منطقيه خالص
احنا عندنا في العربي ماضي حاضر مستقبل في
الانجليزي لا في الانجليزي الماضي التام
المستمر اللي هو
فبدات ان انا اعمل فيديوهات عن الانجليزي
بدات ان انا اصور فيديوهات عن المذاكره
اللي كنت بقوله لاصحابي بقيت بقوله
فيديوهات بدات ان انا اتكلم عن التركيز في
المذاكره اني ناس كتيره مش عارفه تركز
اتعلمت المونتاج عملت فيديو للمونتاج ومع
الوقت مع الوقت كل الحاجات دي وصلتني في
النهايه ان انا اسيب شغلنتي خالص كمهندس
اللي ما كانش حاجه جامده اصلا يعني الناس
دايما بتظن ان واحد ساب الهندسه وراح يعمل
حاجه تانيه انت بتضحي بخمس سنين يا راجل
ده كانوا عذاب ما يعني ايه الواحد يزعل
عليها قوي يعني
فسبت الهندسه خالص
ورحت اليوتيوب
الموضوع ده انت بتسمعه دلوقتي يمكن سمعته
كتير وقتها ما كانش الموضوع ده منتشر
وقتها كان ارتديت اللي هو يا ابني يعني
انت انت كويس يعني افتكر صديق للوالد
قابلني في مره ايه شغال فين ومش عارف ايه
وده كان اصعب سؤال بتسالني وقتها لان انا
سبت الشغل وبشتغل
على النت
نظره الاسى واللي هو يعني كان بيقول لي
ابوك رضي في الرضا ان انت تعمل كده اقول
له اه وبيشجع والله غلطان
ففعلا الموضوع مش متقبل خالص وفي نهايه
المطاف يعني الموضوع بينتهي عند سؤال طب
الموضوع ده بيجيب فلوس اه طب الحمد لله
كويس
وكان يعني ايه ودي نقطه مهمه جدا يعني
خاصه في الاهالي
ان فعلا ممكن ابنك او بنتك او انت او انت
من بدري يكون في مصدر للدخل بشكل ما ولو
استثمرت وقت في الموضوع ده ممكن الموضوع
يكبر به كتير يكبر
ويمكن يتخطى فكره المرتب اللي هيجي لك من
الوظيفه لو اتخرجت واشتغلت الوظيفه
التقليديه بتاعتنا يعني
نقطه مهمه جدا ناخد بالنا منها ان مدام
الموضوع في نهايه المطاف هو الفلوس فنركز
على الحاجات المهمه
بس طبعا ده مش معناه كل الناس يجيبوا بقى
ويروحوا ويشتغلوا يوتيوبرز مش قصدي كده
خالص بس فكره ان في حاجات اكثر بكثير من
اللي معروضه قدامنا دلوقتي المهم سبت
الشغل والحمد لله تفرجت للموضوع ده وبدات
استغل الحاجات اللي انا كويس فيها
وكانت اقوى حاجه بالنسبه لي هي طرح
الامثله الاتيان بامثله تبسط المفاهيم
المجرده مين بيدرس فلسفه يعني
كويس ما فيش اوكي طيب حاجه زي ازاي توصل
لواحد ان الحماس مش هو اهم حاجه يقول لك
ازاي ده انا ما بشتغلش الا لما اكون متحمس
ده انا لما بكون متحمس بابدع في الحاجه
اللي انا بعملها ولكن في الواقع الحماس
شيء لا يعتمد عليه خالص عمره قصير بالضبط
زي عود الكبريت كده عود الكبريت ده وظيفته
ان احنا نولع به السبرتايه ونعمل عليه
فنجان القهوه
وظيفته ان احنا نشعل شيء اكثر دواميه
علشان نقدر نسوي القهوه ولكن اعتمادك على
الحماس كانك بتولع عود كبريت وتشغل
السبرتايه وتسخن الكنكه انطفا تولع عود
تاني وتسخن الكنكه هل ممكن لو استمرنا الى
الابد الكنكه دي تستوي بالاسلوب ده
استحاله ففايده الحماس انه يشعل شيء اكثر
دواميه شيء او سيستم او عادات معينه
تساعدك في النهايه ان انت توصل للحاجه
اللي انت بتعملها عملنا الفيديو ده وفعلا
وصل الفكره لناس كتيره جدا فيديو اخر هو
ازاي تستمتع بحياتك رغم الصعوبات
كلنا بلا استثناء عندنا مشاكل في حياتنا
مشاكل اسريه مشاكل مرضيه مشاكل مع الجيران
مشاكل مع العيله مشاكل في الشغل مشاكل في
الدراسه مشاكل في المستقبل كلنا عندنا
مشاكل
بس رغم كده بتلاقي في ناس قادره تستمتع
بحياتها
في ناس رغم المشاكل قادر ان هو يقضي يوم
وعادي وما فيش اي مشكله خالص في حين ان في
ناس كتيره وانا كنت منهم ساعه ما تحصل لك
مشكله الدنيا بتقف تسود في وشك ما تعرفش
تعمل اي حاجه خالص لحد ما المشكله دي تخلص
تعيش شويه وبعدين تحصل مشكله تانيه وهكذا
موضوع مرهق جدا
فقرات كتاب يعني استفدت منه في ازاي تقدر
تستمتع بحياتك رغم الصعوبات ولكن الكلام
المباشر
في الغالب بيبان كليشيه وبديهي ولكن لا
يؤثر
الكلام المباشر يبان حلو جدا بس ما بياثرش
اتعودنا عليه وده ان اتعودت عليه لما
بتنور مثال جديد للشخص لا بيستوعب الموضوع
افضل فمن هنا جيت فكره الحبر والميه
والطبق
مش عارف اسمه ايه ده استانلس
التعليقات
كثير
فكره ان نقطه الحبر دي هي المشكله تبدا
صغيره جدا ولكن انت اللي بتكبرها من خلال
التفكير فيها بشكل دائم ولكن لو قدرت
تحصرها من البدايه هتقدر تستمتع بالحتت
الرائقه ديت الصافيه النقيه ديت وترجع
للمشكله بتاعتك تفكر فيها براحتك ولكن في
الاطار بتاعها
شيل جميل
ان يكون عارفين طبعا مش الشيء الجميل
الشيء المؤسف كلنا عارفين ان اللي حصل في
سوريا وتركيا والناس تهدمت بيوتها وكده
عجالي والله رسايل وتعليقات ان فعلا
الفيديو ده ساعه بعض الناس ان هي تتخطى
المصيبه او الفاجعه اللي حصلت لهم ربنا
يعافيهم يعني جميعا
فكره حاجه بسيطه زي ان انا بعرف اجيب
امثله تبسط المفاهيم المجرده ساعه حد في
بلد تانيه خالص ان هو يتخطى ازمه وابتلاء
شديد واحد ما كانش يقدر يتخيل في البدايه
خالص ان حاجه زي دي ممكن تحصل
كنت في السعوديه قابلت صديقي عبد الله
العلاوي
الرائع رائع جدا يعني اتمنى ان انتم
تتابعوه
فكان بيكلمني عن مشكله الانطفاء
لو انتم بتتابعوا يوتيوبرز فعارفين دايما
ان في فترات كده دول بيكتئبه ملوش محتوى
يبطلوا خالص تمام فكان بيشتكي لي من
الموضوع ده وللاسف الشديد ناس كتيره بتبطل
من الحفره دي يقع في الحفره دي ما يقومش
منها خالص
كلمته عن فكره ان لما بتكون متحمس انت
بتكون زي الجمره مشتعله مضيئه عماله تشع
ضوء وحراره ويا سلام ما فيش اجمل من كده
ولكن هي مش هتخليها كده مش تخليها كده
للابد هيجي لها فتره وخلاص هتخفض هتبقى
تراب
الشيء الجميل ان التراب حتى لو الناس يعني
اللي بيعملوا التراب اللي هو بعد الانطفاء
ده لو حطيت عليه فحم جديد وشويه هواء يبدا
يشتغل تاني فتقبلك للسايكل ديت هيساعدك
انك تتخطى الموضوع ده وتتقبله
شيء جميل ان عبد الله كان قاعد بقى له
اسبوعين ما بينزلش فيديوهات يومين اتنين
نازل فيديو وقال لي انا اول مره اشوف
الموضوع بالشكل ده
طبعا انا مش جاي هنا عشان اقول ان انا
عبقري وجامد جدا وبقول لهم كل الناس
ولكن الحقيقه انا جاي هنا عشان اقول
ان
كلنا عندنا حاجات احنا كويسين فيها ومش
شايفينها
فلما تشوف حاجه كويسه في حد قل له هو مش
عارف والله ما عارف عرفه هو نفسه مش عارف
ما تخليش فكره ان انت تقول لحد ان هو كويس
في حاجه ده يكون بمثابه اعتراف ضمني منك
ان انت سيء فيها لا
خالص وصدقني الحاجه اللي انت بتعملها ديت
هتلف وترجع لك
خليك انت اول ده
زقه وصدقني هيلف وهتلاقي حد هيزقك زقه
اقوى كمان يعني زي ما عز وجل بيقول هل
جزاء الاحسان الا الاحسان
شكرا